I want to start maybe just by addressing
a couple things that were you know that
we're on my mind about what I learned
from you and then I want to ask you kind
of like a first powerful question so
this this quote was at the beginning of
incognito man is equally incapable of
seeing the nothingness from which he
emerges and the infinity in which he is
engulfed yeah that was Rene Descartes
and I've always been fascinated by this
issue about the little strip perception
that we live on which is to say the way
we perceive the world has everything to
do with what is useful for us so we
perceive a little tiny strip to the
electromagnetic spectrum we perceive a
little tiny strip of hearing frequencies
that we can hear and so on things that
are useful for finding food and mates
and so on but you know what the last few
centuries have taught us is what's going
on in the world of let's say molecules
are quantum mechanics and atoms and so
on and at one end of the other end of
the scale you know the solar systems and
galaxies in the cosmos and it's very
difficult for us as humans to really
understand the world and either those
scales even though that is just as much
the reality as ours is but we just
happened to be in this little strip
where we feel comfortable and and we
have to work really really hard to
understand reality at those scales so I
really love that quotation from
Descartes and then it's like humans are
right in the middle between the cosmic
perspective and the molecular atomic
perspective we're like smack in the
middle
you've right visible light spectrums all
we see just this tiny little fraction of
what actually exists all these cellphone
signals that are just going through you
every single moment there's so much more
though that I want to just even from the
beginning here you call yourself a
possibility
I've said is a student of the universe
you're you're looking for what could be
for what can be yeah essentially the
idea with pasta billion ism is simply
just in a few sentences it's just that
you know
our choice seems to be when we come to
the world is okay you can buy into a
particular religious story or you can do
the thing where you say you know science
has got all the answers it's not that
I'm strict atheist and and when you go
to a bookstore you see books on both of
these sides but but I feel like as a
scientist I have to admit about the
limits of our certainty and uncertainty
and so my interest is in building out
the structure of the possibility space
instead of fighting and dying for one
particular story instead figuring out
like okay what what could be what are we
doing here what is going on and so you
know I to my mind that seems like a more
a more modern approach rather than
saying well I think this particular
deity exists because my parents told me
or I think we've got it all figured out
there's no more mystery in the cosmos
because every good scientist will tell
you that we don't understand even the
basics we don't know how consciousness
arises from pieces of parts we don't
know how life started on earth the
origin of life on Earth you know we have
these stories like wow maybe there was
lightning and that caused amino acids
come to place and then amino ad and then
they started doing this thing
individually got cells above it there's
a whole narrative that we can spin we
don't know if that's you know so what am
I meant to Francis what's that
panspermia exactly so one of my mentors
Francis Crick wrote a paper saying you
know maybe maybe life here on earth was
seeded from somewhere else
as in you know an asteroid came in and
there was some life on the asteroid and
so on we can't